une journée d'observation
d'apprentissage d'émotion pour la
semaine du handicap la commune de
mantes-la-jolie a participé pour la
première fois au duo des six paires
entre employés et personnes en situation
de handicap ont été formés pour une
journée découverte parmi eux
mélanie et christine suis avec christine
pour cette journée des duos d où je vais
lui montrer en fait un petit peu notre
environnement de travail
ce que je peux faire à l'accueil que ce
soit en état civil ou même au standard
ça se passe bien avec ma marraine
voilà qui mal avec ma petite fille à la
76e pour cette journée et j'espère que
voilà que ça va permettre une vocation
chez elle et que et qui sait peut-être
que ça va devenir une collègue dans le
futur une sensibilisation professionnels
sur la base du volontariat que la mairie
de mantes-la-jolie a tenu à coeur de
maintenir l'objectif aussi c'est aider
ces personnes là à sortir un peu de
l'isolément de ne pas rester seul c'est
pour ça qu'il ya quelqu'un à côté et que
il accompagne le handicap c'est pas
uniquement être quelqu'un de dépendance
est aussi quelqu'un qui peut travailler
normalement avec des petites adaptations
de son environnement de travail dernier
gréco sourds travaille depuis vingt ans
à la mairie ce handicap n'est pas
pénalisant pour son travail un système
d'interprète en ligne a même été mis en
place pour l'aider ah ben c'est vrai que
c'est très différent par rapport au
début
les méthodes ont beaucoup changé ont
évolué on est beaucoup plus sur
l'informatique actuellement il ya des
logiciels de passer par les cris aussi
parfois pour s'exprimer par le mime donc
enfin comme moi j'ai vraiment l'habitude
voilà j'ai cette expérience de
communiquer comme ça sans soucis depuis
toujours un duo d pour initier des
potentiels futurs employés mais aussi
pour sensibiliser chacun aux faits que
travail et handicap ne sont pas
incompatibles